now I've had a lot going on over the
past couple of years we've covered a lot
of ground I think you know I've become a
best-selling children's author as you
know a filmmaker a women's studies
expert a transphobe of the Year among
other accolades but many people don't
realize where this all started for me
where my journey began they don't know
who I was before all of this they don't
understand that at my roots I am really
a music critic and and specifically a
rap critic and that's where it all began
for me so today I'm getting back to my
roots a little bit where it all began
and um as not so much a rap critic but
as a rap appreciator an analyst a
scholar of the genre and on that note I
am now going to give
for some reason my definitive ranking of
the and I I had to boil it down a little
bit because I could go on forever on
this subject but it's going to be the
four greatest rap songs of all time
there's always a debate about this of
course uh but we're gonna settle that
debate once and for all and uh works
good on the list four to one so let's
get into it first on the list is a name
that long time listeners of this show
are familiar with and you're expecting
it to be on the list and of course it is
uh we begin at number four with my guy
poo shiesty Mr Pooh has been a favorite
of mine ever since he burst onto the
scene in 2020 with his classic back in
Blood let's listen a little bit of that
now
[Music]
I ain't got nowhere to go I shot up
every word
[Music]
today
wow just tremendous it gets better every
time I hear it um the part that
resonates with me the most the part that
I really can feel and that I can relate
to is where he talks about uh shooting
up the club and as it happens push
heisty was arrested a year later for
actually shooting up a club allegedly
allegedly actually shooting up a club
and needless to say who sheist he's
innocent he's also innocent of the armed
robbery charges and the uh aggravated
assault and battery charges and federal
conspiracy charges all from different
alleged crimes that were all allegedly
committed allegedly in the two years
after this song came out
um but Pooh is innocent this is the
system yet again trying to keep a young
black man down and now he's in prison
for the next five years and the world is
going to be deprived of the sweet sounds
of poo which I think is the greatest
tragedy and travesty of all
um here's all I'll say about this and I
don't want to get off on a whole tangent
about it but listen just because a guy
says repeatedly in a song Hey I like to
shooting Rob people and then you're out
and you see someone who looks like that
guy shooting and robbing people
correlation
is not the same as causation so you
can't jump to any assumptions based on
that which is why I say as always free
[Music]
moving on to uh number three on our list
of the greatest rap songs of all time
this one is slightly more obscure I
think it did get 20 million views on
YouTube this is from the artist
645ar uh because rap artists these days
are choosing rap names that sound like
the password you use for your Gmail
account or something one seven three
four six seven three two one four seven
six Charlie three two seven eight but
it's called Ford trap is the name of the
song and it's uh and I think you'll see
why but it's easily the third greatest
rap song of all time let's check it out
[Music]
that I'm sorry I was just it I
it fills me with joy when I hear such
beautiful music that is a real thing
apparently that's not a it's not a joke
and why would it be why would it be a
joke not a joke
that is not a joke that is a natural
fact it's like if Mickey Mouse grew up
in a fatherless home this is what the
music would sound like and this is how
you get credibility in the streets by
the way you know it's yeah you just if
you want if you want to go out go down
to the streets and be taken seriously
take a hit from a helium balloon Instant
Respect
but mainly I love this song because it
sounds like something that an insect
might sing it answers the question we've
all asked which is what would it sound
like if a housefly or a mosquito became
a rapper what's up what's up what's up I
be flossing
[Music]
Ivy Florissant and for answering that
question alone I think it deserves to be
number uh three on the list if you ever
read the fine print that appears when
you started browsing an incognito mode
it says that your activity might still
be visible to your employer your school
your internet service provider well to
actually stop people from monitoring
your online activity you need to do what
I do and use expressvpn think about all
the times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee
shop hotel or even a friend's house
without expressvpn every site you visit
can be logged by the Admin of that
Network that's still true even when
you're in incognito mode expressvpn is
an app that encrypts all of your network
data and reroutes it to a network of
secure servers so your private online
activity stays private expressvpn is
super easy to use the app has one button
you tap it to connect and your browsing
activity is secure it's as simple as
that stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com walshyt use my Link at
expressvpn.com walshyt to get three
extra months free that's exp resvpn.com
Walsh YT number two second greatest rap
song of all time from an artist who has
created so many incredible songs was
hard to choose hard to really Whittle it
down but I'm going with the classic okay
so this is Lil xan and I know when I say
best little xan song you're all going to
say with me now wake up is obviously his
best song I know you've heard this a
million times but let's go ahead and
play it
[Music]
yeah
I mean truly this is the song that for
me signals that we're living through
another age of artistic Brilliance you
know this is this is how the people who
are alive during the Renaissance
probably felt they had Michelangelo and
da Vinci we have Lil xan now there are
some who will look at that comparison
and say that it's evidence that the
world's coming to an end that Art Is
Dead that we're the dumbest generation
of humans to ever walk the earth there
are some who will listen to Lil xan and
lose their will to live
but those people just aren't able to
hear and understand the true lyrical and
Musical and poetic Genius of lilzan
because listen to these lyrics again
okay just to just to recite the lyrics
again I wake up I throw up I feel like
I'm dead a I the game up yeah I
drew the game up yeah we do not play
brah yeah in my own lane bruh who that
is lame bro listen to that there
that is lame bro you know you as a lame
hoe my from overstate what you
mean what you mean what you mean yeah
indeed what do you mean what does he
mean what does anything mean and I think
that is the point that Lil xan is trying
to make he's trying to capture the
Primal essence of a man looking out into
the world and seeing chaos and and
randomness
from his perspective everywhere not
understanding not comprehending it's the
fear of non-comprehension I think is
what Lil xan is trying to capture he's
quite ingeniously I think bringing out
that visceral bewilderment that
confusion that we all sometimes
experience when we look at the state of
the world what you mean he asks and he's
not asking he's imploring he's saying
he's saying to you ask the question
what does it all mean it's not so much a
song as a desperate plea a cry from the
darkness
beseeching The Listener to question to
think to search
and to learn and that brings us finally
to the greatest rap song of all time
this is a song that has garnered 840
million views on YouTube nearly a
billion okay nearly a billion views to
this masterpiece as you probably expect
it's a song from my favorite personal
favorite artist of all time takashi69
and it's called Gooba let's listen now
we catch him at the tickets
[Music]
stupid
oh my God uh it's really stunning to
encounter
raw unvarnished artistic Brilliance like
that
I mean let's go listen to those lyrics
one more time now we catch him at the
chicken spot up a couple chops put that
n-word with a hundred shots
Day Day made that N word Diddy Bop cha
cha cha cha he thought he was gonna
knuckle up I don't box and these n-words
always talking yada yada yah when you
see me what you talking about you
talking about listen to this part n
words always want to chase cloud
I am Cloud now when you hear that the
first thing you think is well first you
think wait a minute isn't Takashi 69
Mexican or something and so why is he
allowed to use the n-word so freely
what's going on here the second thing
you think is wow this makes me angry it
makes me angry
at Beethoven and Mozart that they never
made music half as profound as this
[Music]
it makes me glad that they're dead and
that they are an ash in the ground
because they don't compare to Takashi 69
bro what the what did you just say
we could obviously spend all day
dissecting the lyrics uh but this the
part that really stuck out at me again
was when he said and he's n-word's
always talking when you see me what
you're talking about you're talking
about they always want to chase Cloud I
am Cloud when I hear those lyrics what I
think takashi69 is trying to convey is
like the futility of of words of speech
compared with action you know he says
what you talking about and we're always
talking
this is a man who's not so much lashing
out at his enemies but rather at in many
ways the lethargy and ambivalence of the
Modern Age he said don't sit still okay
don't stand off to the side
thinking you can substitute words for
Action this is very much like
Roosevelt's man in the arena speech
except in every way better and more
eloquent
um Takashi 69 implores us to be men of
action
I am clout he says and this is an Ode to
the act of becoming to the process of of
doing of acting in which we are all
transformed that's what I take from the
song anyway and it is why
I believe that it is the greatest rap
song of all time indeed probably the
greatest song period of all time
couldn't remember
[Music]
oh